foreign
[Music]
well hello dear friends uh thank you for
joining us for our program I'd like to
know
a question and answer program where you
send us the questions and we do
everything possible to do research and
find answers to your questions this
program takes place uh once a week and
I'd like to give you the address where
you can send us your questions
electronic address you'll see it on the
screen TV at some tv.org once again
TV at some
tv.org we'd be delighted to get your
questions uh we probably will delay in
answering the questions because we have
many many that have been sent to us and
this is only a half hour program once a
week which uh in the future we plan to
expand but send them to us be patient
and we will answer them in the order in
which we receive them I have with me
Pastor Daniel Miranda who is the
associate pastor of Fresno Central
Seventh-day Adventist Church my old alma
mater
and he's associate pastor there with
Pastor govaya who helps us here also at
sequence unsealed and he also comes and
he helps us with programming still and
we appreciate that thank you so much for
being with us Pastor Miranda thank you
Pastor board for allowing me to still be
part of this program
that I enjoy very much I know you enjoy
it because you keep coming back
praise the Lord we're very glad to have
him very Bible knowledgeable very humble
and God is using him powerfully at
Fresno Central Church and also here uh
on our some TV programming so we want to
begin with a word of prayer we have
several interesting questions today so
if you would lead us in prayer please
let us pray
dear heavenly father
you have told us that we should not open
the word of God without prayer
so we seek that face at this time we
want to ask you Lord to direct us and
lead us in this program and also those
who are watching I pray that your Holy
Spirit May Enlighten their minds so that
this study that we're going to have may
be productive to our spiritual lives in
the name of Jesus we pray amen amen
all right the first question
I think that you have the answer to
there it's um
it's regarding different editions of the
book great controversy
the question is this we are aware that
there are three editions of the great
controversy
1884 1888 and 1911. why are there three
editions which Edition do you recommend
actually there are four editions the
first is called spiritual gifts which is
four little volumes and actually four
and two volumes which forms the
foundation for what later becomes uh
spirit of Prophecy and great controversy
but what can we say about why there are
four editions and how they relate to
each other yes
so the the great controversy Motif in
the visions of Ellen White was gradual
in its development
the the first time that she received the
vision of the great controversy theme
was in 1858 at lavis Grove Ohio she was
there doing a funeral and all of a
sudden she was taking up a vision and
the vision lasted several hours where
she saw the scope of the great
controversy from the time that Satan
rebelled in Heaven until the end of sin
and of the great controversy so this
gives a as a result of this Vision she
writes a little volume of 219 pages and
today as you said this is spiritual
gifts volume one and it is completely
reproduced in early writings now it took
the story from the fall of Lucifer to
the fall of Adam and Eve immediately to
Jesus's first coming and some of the
events of the New Testament times then
it moved on to matters of the history of
the Christian Church down to the Advent
movement and this soon coming up Jesus
followed by the destruction of sin so
it's a broad sweet abroad it's basically
of a lot of what the Bible says now in
this first part nothing was written on
the Old Testament history she jumps from
from the fall and then goes to Jesus's
time then she spent the rest of her life
enlarging and redefining this theme
volumes 3 and 4A of spiritual gifts
which was published in 1864 filled in
more of the Bible story but in the 1870s
having received more visions and with
more to say she determined to revise and
enlarge the presentation the first three
volumes of the set called Spirit of
Prophecy were published in the 1870s and
covered Bible times but with some
significant gaps the fourth volume was
published in 1884 which is this Edition
that she's mentioning here or he is
mentioning here and be began with the
fall of Jerusalem in 1870 as our current
volume called the Great controversy now
after 1884 Ellen White traveled to
Europe
and then in Europe she was able to visit
some of the places that she had seen in
vision and that gave her a a more Vivid
picture of the things that had happened
during the Reformation so she
improves this version of the fourth
volume of the spirit of Prophecy and
this was then put together in
1888 as the great controversy she also
received additional Visions during that
time not only does he visit the places
in Europe that had been shown to her
Envision before but she also got
additional Visions with additional
information correct that is correct so
then we have in 18 1888 I believe this
was the cold Potter's edition if I'm not
wrong or culpriters use that Edition yes
comporters use this Edition so this was
uh prepared to also reach a non-advinist
public
but then in 1911 while she was still
alive
some minor Corrections were made to the
great controversy for example she had
some chronological statements about
certain events historical events that
she wrote pointing to 1888 but now more
years had passed so they kind of made
those Corrections in regards to time
expressions and that and this is the
addition that we have right now and it's
significant
that Ellen White was alive when those
changes were made and she was consulted
so because she died in 1915. amen so uh
they weren't uh changing things in her
book great controversy without her
knowledge of it and they were just
technical details that dealt mostly with
dates exactly and now an important point
to highlight even though it is not in
the question is that the fact that these
books had to be revised and improved
shows us that inspiration is not given
verbally right we believe it's in
thought inspiration because uh they were
grammatical and and even some
chronological Corrections that were made
but that doesn't affect the message that
God revealed to the prophet basically
what happened with Ellen White is that
God would give her a vision say a vision
of the French Revolution just to use an
example yes and then she would have to
go and write what she saw
with the help of the Holy Spirit the
inspiration of the Holy Spirit helped to
write what she saw in vision
and you know so there was no such as God
dictating everything that Ellen White
had to had to write she grew in her
understanding you know one of my
favorite books is the book early
writings and the reason why I like early
writings is because it's succinct so
simple in other words you find you find
more clearly the sequence of end time
events because you don't have a great
expansion that where you say well where
does this end and where the where does
this begin the book early writings the
chronology is very easy to follow it is
and uh and when you compare it of course
with the expansion in great controversy
then you get the complete picture
yep
so which Edition would you recommend
password
all of the above
I I believe that you need to compare
there are some things in the 1911
Edition that were left that that were in
that were in the 1884 Edition that were
left out in the 1911. one for example is
Satan's personation of Christ coming yes
you know there's manuscript 16 1884.
which clearly is describing the same
impersonation that is described in the
1911 Edition but it has so many more
details that when you than what you find
in the 1911 Edition so just compare all
of them do a study of all of them yes
very good
but the final product is the great
controversy of 1911.
okay what's the next question that we
have okay the next question here ask
actually a question for you it's on the
series of Matthew 24 in episode 4.
um you mentioned the following
Pompeii adopted a God Mithra Pompeii
made the eagle the soul standard of the
Roman Legions
the eagle standard was linked to the
worship of Mithra Sun God
flavius Josephus said that the legions
would put their standard on the ground
and worship it I suppose this also
happened in 1866 Siege of Jerusalem
Pastor I'm really struggling to find
this detail in the words of the Jews or
in the internet and I really like the
link or typology you made with the first
destruction of Jerusalem Ezekiel 8
Abomination the second also and possibly
the second one
uh can you please help me with detailed
references of where you got these
details from please
so that I may check and be able to bless
others
okay may I first of all recommend that
the person who has the question which I
don't think we have a name we have a
just HP
um
but the first thing that I would
recommend is that you get my notes on
Daniel 8.
they're available here from Secrets
unsealed just request the notes on
Daniel 8. and there I go through the
whole transfer of
um you know the worship of the Sun from
ancient Babylon to pergamum to the Roman
Empire to the papacy to apostate
protestantism in other words there's a
chain where all of this is passed along
in the course of history so I would
recommend get that study on Daniel
chapter 8 notes on Daniel 8. secondly
there were two volumes that were written
by Humphrey Prado that's p-r-i-d-e-a-u-x
uh where he deals with the history of
Persia
and I got a lot of the details about uh
you know the Mithra mithraism uh from
those books uh also uh the book by Franz
Kumon that's
c-u-m-o-n-t the mysteries of Mithra and
he wrote other books as well where he
deals with the issue of how uh the god
Sun God Mithra was adopted by the Roman
Legions and so on uh and then where I
got specifically that pompe made the
eagle the lone standard I got from the
interpreters dictionary of the Bible so
there are several sources that I got
these details from and I would recommend
that the person you know if you're
really seriously want to get into this
that you would get those works and of
course when it comes to Josephus
uh it would be Wars of the Jews
okay that's really good
so do your research and
enrich your knowledge on this and
Humphrey perdo might not be on the
internet might might not be able to find
it because these volumes were written a
couple of centuries ago so they're older
books you know where historians dealt
with history and they didn't see try to
interpret history
you know they actually uh related
history as it as it occurred so anyway
okay now we have another question
uh and this one I wasn't able to make
sense of but I'll read it anyway
um I think I saw one or a one or two
minute video summarizing a Bible
Doctrine could you direct me to these
I suspect and I'm not sure about this
that this person might be referring to
Pastor govaya's series but if more than
two minutes where he is expounding upon
the doctrines of The Seventh-Day
Adventist Church it takes longer than a
couple of minutes but uh I have a strong
suspicion that this person might be
referring to that being that Pastor
govea does programming with us as well
so I would recommend that this person go
to the um the Fresno Central website and
you're going to find Pastor govais I
think he's done the first 12 of those
where he covers the doctrines of the
church okay but I don't other than that
I don't know what Bible Doctrine is
being referred to in this particular
question
okay what's our next question
I think about the word Daybreak yes all
right very good so it says here I am
having an issue with the word the Greek
word
August I'll guess
which is only used once in the New
Testament and translated as they break
in Acts 20 verse 11.
are we to take this to mean at Sunrise
or are we to take this to mean at the
beginning of the next day in the evening
morning cycle
if Paul came to them on the evening of
the first day of the week or are
Saturday night and the text said that he
would be leaving the next day that would
mean that he was to leave on the second
day of the week however
if it sells if it says Paul talked from
that evening
through midnight until the day break
if we are to take day break as meaning
Sunrise then it would only be the second
half of the first day of the week or our
Sunday morning rather than during the
second day of the week being our Sunday
night till the beginning of our Sunday
night for Monday night
but if we are to take day break as
meaning the start of the next day Paul
would have been leaving those he was
talking to sometime after the evening
started on the second day or our Sunday
night thus the only way the only way
Paul could have left the next day would
be if the word I'll guess actually means
at the beginning of the next day
and that Paul left during the evening or
morning of the second day of the week
and yet all translations I can find
translate our guess as Daybreak Dawn
daylight and even the break of the day
and therefore I struggle
kind of like
complicated a little bit
the way it's fresh I think I think
sometimes we complicate the Bible more
than the Bible is
um
the Adventist Church has generally
agreed that the meeting that the Apostle
Paul had in troas was a meeting that
took place on Saturday night that's the
that's the consensus
um it was the first day of the week the
dark portion of the first day of the
week
so Daybreak would simply mean when the
sun came up the next morning which would
be our Sunday morning yes that's the
simplest way to understand it
um so I don't know if you have any
additional words of wisdom on this I
have concluded the same as you mentioned
it
they break here for me is the Sunday
morning first day of the week where he
left yeah but even even if we if
you know if we would make this
as a reason to keep Sunday because
that's the argument behind it then
actually the text and the argument
itself is saying that Paul actually kept
the Sabbath because he waited to travel
on of course on a regular day of course
you didn't travel on the Sabbath day so
actually this instead of uh saying that
uh or teaching about Sunday sacredness
because Paul celebrated a meeting a
religious meeting on on the first day of
the week actually this is with the
trouble with the trip this is actually
uh
confirming that Paul was a Sabbath
keeper and if if we were to
give a sacred
um
a sacred connotation to a day because
they met on that day
then we should do the same thing for the
rest of the days because the Apostolic
Church in Acts 2 and acts 4 it says that
they would meet and worship God every
day in their homes and they would break
bread right so there is nothing about
Sunday sacredness here yeah clearly this
was an exceptional meeting yes because
they knew that the Apostle Paul was
leaving the next morning and that they
would not see his face again the context
clearly indicates that and uh and so to
make this uh say that really they're
they're observing the first day of the
week in honor of the Resurrection
there's nothing about that in the
passage
you know if it wasn't a Saturday night
which I believe was the dark portion of
the first day of the week
um
would that mean that we're supposed to
have our worship service all night
I'm on Saturday night you know that's
you would have to get that from the text
because the text is not talking about
going to church on Sunday morning and
you know then going out to a restaurant
on Sabbath afternoon and watching the
football game on Sunday afternoon uh no
on Sabbath afternoon it's not talking
about that so you know it's taking a
text out of context and trying to make
it prove what you believe but which is
not not in harmony with the text amen
that's right
anything else
no I think this is all I can say about
that verse you know I've given I've
given an example before of this uh when
I was a teacher of theology in Colombia
um there's this place in the tropical
rainforest that is called kib do oh yeah
yeah you know on the airplane you know
that at that time it was a two two
engine prop and it would come down and
come down it looked like it was going to
land on the trees and suddenly you had
the landing strip and it would land
humid it rains over 300 inches a year
there and when it's raining you're
sweating like crazy it doesn't cool down
the air or anything but anyway uh
a pastor from outside doesn't visit that
area sometimes for weeks or even months
at that time anyway
and so they invited me to come and
preach over a weekend
and you know I preached on Sabbath
morning
and from about until about 12 30 and
they said you're finished already I said
well yeah I preached my sir oh no you
got to preach again and so I preached
again you know and they said that's it
they maybe preached three sermons wow in
a row and then they said okay it's three
o'clock in the afternoon now we're going
to break and we're going to go eat lunch
remember we're going to come back at six
o'clock this evening
and so we came back at six o'clock and
to make a long story short I was
preaching until three o'clock in the
morning wow one sermon after another
now is that something that happens every
week no of course not it's something
that happened in an exceptional way
because I knew I was leaving the next
morning and they wanted to get as much
juice out of the orange as they could so
to speak so that's the type of thing
that happened in Troy is the people knew
that Paul was going to leave the the
next day and they wanted to have him
preach and teach as much as he could
before he left to make this a weekly
occurrence is simply handling the Bible
dishonestly yep completely agree and
um
we shouldn't we we should never make a
Doctrine out of one text
right and this is a an isolated text
when we see this extraordinary case but
uh the evidence is very clear from the
text itself it's a desire to read into
the text it's called I said Jesus rather
than exegesis extracting what the text
is saying
okay the next question I'm not sure that
we're going to have enough time to
answer it but there's actually two
questions by sebesso kalaluka
and one is on Daniel 12 verse 1 and 2
maybe we can answer this one within the
time constraints from this verse I have
heard preachers bring up the topic of a
special Resurrection what is the special
resurrection and can you share the main
idea I tried to search about it but I
only found limited information so what
is the special Resurrection well I know
you are the the expert in Prophecy but I
will give in the few minutes that we
have left the special Resurrection even
though the Bible and the spirit of
Prophecy doesn't use that expression
special Resurrection but it is clear in
Daniel 12 1 and 2 that this Resurrection
is different from the one in first
Thessalonians 4 because in this one we
see both righteous and wicked
resurrecting together right and where
don't resurrect until after the Thousand
Years for General Resurrection that's
correct and in the chronology of Daniel
12 this is not happening after the
Thousand Years this is happening during
the time of God's people that are
delivered from the time of trouble
living when the 144 000 living Saints
are delivered so it can't be after the
Millennium exactly so with that timeline
with that context then we can conclude
that this Resurrection is special it's
different
Revelation chapter 1 verse 7 the bible
says behold he cometh in the clouds and
every eye shall see him and those that
pierced him
so again we see here that not only the
righteous ones will be living and those
who of the wicked that will be living at
that time but also those who pierced him
so we conclude then that this special
Resurrection
takes place a little bit before the
second coming between the sixth and the
seventh Lake and who are resurrected in
this special Resurrection well the
wicked it says Those Who Pierce them
Jesus told Caiaphas that he would see
Jesus coming in the Clouds Of Heaven in
Matthew 26 and also Allen weisers in the
great controversy that
those who Pierce Christ and the mo the
staunch the most staunch enemies of
truth that they will also resurrect in
this special Resurrection yeah I believe
it's a great controversy at least in the
book Edition page 637. okay she actually
quotes Daniel chapter 12 and verse 2 and
she describes the special resurrection
and then the interesting thing is she
goes several Pages after that because at
that point Jesus has not begun his
second coming yet at the special
Resurrection that's at the same moment
that the living Saints are glorified you
have the special Resurrection
and then after that Jesus begins the
second coming and then when he's above
the Earth
once he has not come all the way to the
Earth but once he's above the Earth then
he calls forth those who died before uh
the preaching of the first of the third
Angel's message uh so uh there's a group
of righteous and there's a group of
wicked special groups that resurrect at
that particular time yes
and um
now
who of the righteous will resurrect in
that special Resurrection uh those who
died in the faith of the third Angel's
message according to the spirit of
Prophecy yes and the reason why is
because if the other saints that never
understood the third Angel's message
would resurrect at that moment uh they
would say what's going on here they
wouldn't have any idea what's going on
but those who have understood the third
Angel's message will understand all of
the historical circumstances that are
taking place at that particular time yes
that's correct so it is a privilege to
be part of the Seventh-day Adventist
movement right of this because if we're
faithful then we will be able to see
even if we die we'll be able to see
Jesus coming the entire spectacle right
in other words those who resurrect in
the special Resurrection are besides the
living Saints are the only ones that are
going to see the second coming of Jesus
from beginning to end amen whereas those
who resurrect when Jesus has already
above the Earth not on the Earth but
above the Earth they will only see Jesus
when when he's already arrived
uh so um you know we need to Ellen White
said that we need to struggle with every
Power God has given us to be part of the
144 000 if we're alive at that time and
if not let's make sure that we're in the
special Resurrection amen of those who
died in the third Angel's message amen
praise the lord well anyway our time is
just about up we want to thank you for
tuning in to our program I'd like to
know uh once again I'll give you the
email address TV at some tv.org
TV at some tv.org and we hope to see you
next time on this program send us your
questions God bless and have a very nice
day
[Music]
thank you